thank you guys so much for coming on the
show and being so vulnerable and open
and creating a brand that's really
helping a lot of people look i'm wearing
mad happy right now and i already feel
better what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone do we just become best
friends
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your
favorite sisters twins best friends
enemies sophia and sistine stallone and
we are happy you guys are here we are
having a great morning this is probably
the earliest we've shot which is
different for us but you know what i
kind of feel a lot more energized than i
do when i'm shooting the afternoon just
tell me why
riddle me this yes what we got at the
studio for a 10 am interview yes
everyone's like 10 a.m that's your early
interview
why did i set an alarm for 6 45 i set
one for 6 30. ask us this why why
because
we like to take two hours to get ready
no i don't think it's that i think i was
so anxious and just excited
because it was a morning one
and i was also excited for our guest
today yeah so i was like
i like how you did your makeup today you
put a lot of extra blush on your nose
it's cute you look like a little cindy
lou who
with the braids yeah exactly you do
really like
it
stop with the cobweb anyway
thank you um you know i started wearing
blush on my nose because
since someone said it looks like i got a
nose job i was like great blush was
gonna stay on the nose you know actually
i i watched a tutorial with uh madison
beer shout out um which is really cool
she's pretty good at doing her own
makeup but she's also the most pretty
person ever and here's the thing wait
wait let me easy to do
makeup on a stunning face
i'm pretty much saying i yeah i
completely agree with that because it's
like when you have the perfect structure
nose face eyes hair skin
i mean level up
i mean a little concealer a little blush
you're done yeah i got a lot of
discoloration i got some dark circles
but what my point was was that she did a
lot of blush on her nose yeah and i
thought that was super cute i'm like i
need to bring that back and i just saw
you did it and i go that's a sign i
should do it right
girl talk i mean you might as well set
the oven for 350 degrees because our
faces are caked they're right they
moving speaking of ovens
turn yours on because thanksgiving's
approaching gobble gobble gobble beaches
god i'm so good at transitions these
days she really was i'm sorry did anyone
catch my manscaped transition last week
it was that was pretty freaking freaking
juicy i was
thank god i caught on to that one after
i know anyway it's thanksgiving this
week unpopular opinion it's not my
favorite holiday yes i'm thankful but
the food not a fan you're so
disappointing the only holiday you
actually like is halloween and it's so
quick and it ends in like one night and
usually ends up being horrible
thanksgiving is different because you
know why it's amazing yes does my mom
make us start cooking at seven o'clock
in the morning till eight o'clock at
night
sure foul should we watch eight hours of
the dog show correct do we gamble on
which dog will win
every year the beagle every year
but
it's still the best holiday because the
food for one thing is unreal you guys
it's the one year you can be
basically have a food baby for eight
days but that's why i don't like okay i
also got stomach flu after i ate
thanksgiving on thanksgiving okay first
of all how because everyone else ate the
same thing you did no it wasn't from the
food it was something from prior so um
seeing my thanksgiving meal again later
that evening wasn't exactly
appetizing yeah but that's not a reason
to hate thanksgiving thanksgiving the
after
oh my god do you have any meals i make
after thanksgiving with all the
leftovers i make like the best like
biscuits yeah the leftovers
egg cheese with like some sweet potato
oh my god let's see i'm like foaming at
the mouth at this point i remember
excited i remember in an earlier episode
i think this has to be my favorite
thanksgiving memory we have shared this
story
on the podcast before um but you almost
killed a starting
player for the rounds i'll tell you
right because i think some people forgot
it and this is from our earlier episode
so if you're just joining in i'll just
rehash it really quick yeah i almost
killed an nfl player
starting a rams player a rams player and
i won't say his name but i'm just saying
but he catches your fantasy league would
be
if i did this to him so basically to
make a long story short i'm really
clumsy i can't hold anything with my
fingers i'm bambi when i'm drinking i'm
butter fingers in life so my mom just
told me you know what sophia take the
ceramic bowl out of the oven with mashed
potatoes in it and just put it on the
table
and you know what i do think simple
simple simple task you know what i did i
took it out of the oven
dropped it dropped the potatoes
so it landed on the tin foil covering so
nothing got on the ground so we thought
you know five second rule and so i just
go steam help me sleep sweep it back
into smack it no one saw you can't have
thanksgiving without the mashed potatoes
like
it's just
a passage where it all sort of went
south the potatoes are white the ceramic
bowl was also white
so
when we transferred the potatoes into a
new bowl
you can continue from there yeah well
i'll just skip to the part after which
is i'm cleaning the plates and bowls and
all of this stuff and his wife comes up
to me and goes or to all of us and goes
who held the mashed potatoes who was in
charge of the mashed potatoes
and i go oh that was
me
and she goes
do you realize my husband pulled out
a three inch piece of ceramic from his
mouth that he ate from the mashed
potatoes that he almost swallowed and
she looked at me and she goes you almost
killed him
and to make matters worse she was
holding a one-year-old baby it was just
it was just not mad and i was like oh my
god i am so sorry he was so polite he
didn't see it yeah he did he didn't say
anything
he literally pulls out a three-inch
shard of glass from his mouth sucks it
under a scene he just like puts it in
his napkin says nothing it was bad but
that was my favorite holiday um my
memory from that day and yeah
it's still good it doesn't happen but if
it did well what's going to be
interesting about this thanksgiving is
for the first time we're not gonna be
celebrating it in los angeles we're
cooking or cooking we're gonna be
celebrating in florida it's gonna be
the start of a bunch of new traditions
for us which will be interesting it's
also gonna be weird not
yeah hosting it yourself we're gonna be
the guest of someone else's thanksgiving
you know what's weird a lot of people
have been asking me if it's weird that
we're not if it's weird that we're not
at our childhood home anymore and the
people were selling it and we're like
kind of transferring back and forth
because a lot of people
i think are really nostalgic about it
mm-hmm but we aren't
i could care less i could care less
where they end up they can be in they
can be in missouri fry
this is another place to go
but i think that's it's just interesting
that i don't know what it is about us
that we don't really mind the change i
don't think we have attachment to a lot
of things because our family is very
much bored easily yeah you know so
things we nothing's uh
everything's temporary yeah and you know
also i think that we we always remember
is like if you're kind of going through
this and you're like in a whole other
world and a whole nother life and you're
away from your family and you're not at
your childhood home or they're selling
whatever it is we don't see that as
something to be sad about we're seeing
it as a really exciting new chapter yeah
like thanksgiving yeah we're gonna have
a totally different tradition it's not
gonna be the same routine all the time
but that's also a great thing and i
think that it's important just to
remember you guys like change is good
change is exciting changes new
opportunities home is where the heart is
we'll be with our family yeah that is
going to be enough it is it is plus pie
you know
you know i can make a mean pie yeah i
can make a really good healthy sweet
potato pie disgusting actually speaking
of that guess what sophia guess what
sophia orders yesterday
sweet potato ice cream i will see you in
court it was so cool i will see you in
the pool salt and straw right now it's
an ice cream shop has thanksgiving
flavors did i try
the
turkey gravy and cranberry sauce yeah
did i like it i don't know but i'm sorry
i cut the cameras i have my people see
your people you're gonna hear from my
course you're gonna hear from my
attorney no it was so good you guys they
had like this cheesecake walnut one i
tried this poor lady i was standing in
there and i asked for the literally i'm
like can i draw that one that one
there's a whole line behind me
worth it got really good i feel like the
people that work at a soft serve or some
sort of ice cream place hate
when people like me asks for a sample of
everything the problem is is this and
you guys i'm gonna encourage this i had
such a craving yesterday for ice cream
and i was thinking about it all day and
you know i'm one of those people i like
to be healthy we all like to be healthy
but this time i'm like you know what
if you're wanting it go get it because
after i had it i went to bed smiling
yeah baby it's like it's fix season
build that extra layer of sweater i need
to get a little cushion in my pushes
push-up wait
you got it do it again
cushioning right push it
cushion cushioning in my tuition what's
the no you're not more cushioning my
tushing push into my tissue
pushing for the point oh no get a little
in the tush because you're in the toilet
that sounds horrible
hold on anyway
anyway yeah you ordered sweet potato ice
cream which i was like is sophia trying
to be healthy well yes it was just a
great day because we also got to watch
the barbie movie oh
yeah
no
barbie black swan
anyone else
black swan oh wait natalie portman oh
wait wait where are you
can i just say the music scoring is
chef's kiss yeah it is really good the
instrumentals stunning so good i did not
appreciate it when i was a child yeah i
know and the characters just perfect
who's the director are you trying to
have them on the podcast i mean but
honestly there's not one barbie movie i
don't like
except today's
there's like a season of barbie movies
there was like rapunzel it was the
mermaid one there was a fairy one you
know what it is it's like not crap
animation is almost too good today yeah
it's almost too realistic
jinx
you owe me a
what are we like we don't like soda cake
you don't eat game pops either you owe
me um no but it was like i think it's so
funny because when we were a kid
watching that movie a hundred times over
we were so nostalgic yeah like the
graphics the food and i'm watching it as
an adult i was like this is the
shittiest quality but it's still so yeah
i thought that the prince in the film
was super hot he's like he's a like he
looks like a doll he has no nose he
doesn't even talk his mouth isn't even
open but it was so good selling
nostalgic and i posted on my uh close
friends i was like this guy's the boat
he's the evil guy with like the huge
bird nose and he becomes a bird i'm not
just saying that and everyone was like
yeah he sucks
oh my god everyone knows even guys
really real ones out there know what
we're talking about oh also yesterday
sophia and i spontaneously decided to go
to a comedy show yesterday which was day
for us it was
ice cream and comedy guys crazy
um but it was it was really cool because
it's finally opening back up and that's
something that sophie and i used to love
i love going to going to
and i don't know why we were sitting in
the audience the whole time i was like i
guarantee i could make all these people
laugh well you know why because everyone
sucked that night
everyone did suck last night i'm sorry
i'm not going to like beat up that's
true that it wasn't it wasn't we left
early and i was super disappointed with
the lineup i know but i honestly thought
i could get up there and do it better oh
yeah i've always wanted to i don't know
i'll tell you what it is my type of
stand-up would be very self-deprecating
it would always be stories about how i
screw up in life and like my sadnesses
but that's what's funny we're so good at
self-deprecating that people like to
hear the people's pain because it
distracts from their own life no
completely but i've always wanted to we
always say this we want uh david spade
did this segment on his show where he
had like an earpiece in and he would
tell some person random on stage like
what to say yeah and it seems so funny
and i think it'd be really funny if he
did that for us so david's baby you're
listening to this we are
available we are available we are open
arms open ears
all right oh since they're saying else
but that's like open no tummies
[Laughter]
okay but no it was open ears okay open
ears but we should do it it'd be fun i
know i'm actually
very anxious for this weekend why is
that
because
i'm getting introduced to a new group of
people and i get so
nervous when i meet a new friend group
or like you're the new person in an
already established friend group because
i don't know
their history the way they act what they
like to talk about because
my personality could be a hundred
different things and sometimes i wear
different hats for certain people
because i want to make sure everyone
likes me which is just a terrible way to
live but i hate not being liked no i
think everyone can relate to that when
you're walking into a new friend group
or if you're dating someone you're
meeting their friends for the first time
you know it is kind of important to make
an impression and it's like you don't
want to force it and you don't want to
be something you're not but you also
don't want to be
something that everyone hates because
there's one thing that i do know about
when you're dating someone or you're
being introduced to a friend group your
friends will mention something to you if
they don't like who you're dating or if
you brought a friend that they don't
like you know what i'm saying so
i think a lot of people can relate to
that but at the same time like
when anybody sit at home the whole time
i basically sat at home i remember i was
at an event the other night and
i was so nervous in the social setting
with all of these girls around me that i
went to the bathroom and i faced time
new for 25 minutes i sat in the bathroom
stall and facetime sofia for 20 minutes
and that's something i used to do all
the time i know
i know it's it's a mentality thing and
it's also just when you have but you
were also in a group where you don't
really love the group sometimes no one
doesn't work but i didn't even give them
a chance i was so nervous to even
put myself out there i don't know i
don't know i don't think it's a bad
thing that you want to make a good
impression or that you're nervous and i
also think that
i mean maybe other people feel this way
i don't know if you are one way on the
outside and you're you're both like an
ex uh what's it called a
um you're introverted and extroverted
but sometimes your introvertedness can
come out when because i know like
cysteine you come off as an extrovert
but you're very introverted like you
have your side so you like to be alone
you like to have your routine you like
to be
i mean like you like to have a little
bit more control what's going on and
like in this situation you can't control
what people think you can't control what
people say and all you can do is just be
you but then you also don't want to like
wear yourself out because you're trying
to be perfect too i totally agree i
would love for that to be my
new year's resolution is to stop
finding uh approval from strangers yeah
and just do me well i i've realized that
i mean i think that you can relate to
this too is that i don't feel like i try
anymore to be perfect with people
because i just know like if you like me
then you like me if you don't then you
don't like i don't i don't want to be
around people that don't like me and i
also and if you don't big mistake
because you know who's behind my back
this one and who's behind her back this
one she could throw a mean punch yeah i
am i'm the bulldog and you're also the
you're like the little terrier i'm like
a chihuahua that'll bite your ankle
really hard and actually leave you with
this oh the
some people bite your lip off
oh
yeah you do though sophia like in a club
i'll i'll be the one that's pushed and
you will get in this girl's face i'm
like you will get hit yeah
you will will you take a punch for me
yeah well at least you're coming with me
and we're going to be together
nice and i think honestly it's justine
and i and i don't this kind of actually
this is a hack if you don't want to go
somewhere and you're nervous to go bring
the person that you feel the most
comfortable with with you because i'm
telling you and you know by the way and
it has to be a person
that is on the same wavelength as you
with terms of how long they like to stay
how long they like to we know when to
drink or not drink exactly like we are
always
never not on the same page sophie and i
are professionals at the irish exit yes
we don't say anything we just know who
wants to hi buy like 12 people
people i'm sorry to put like really like
do you you can just walk out no it's so
true i'm going to text them in the i'm
really happy that we're at the age where
we can sort of our friend groups are now
meshed together we can both go out and
drink and we also both hide in the
bathroom together yeah so like we can go
to everything together yeah we also give
each other like a look or just needing
help where we're at see that's some
sister to love with you it is sister
telepathy you know we also look very
like so it's
it makes it even scarier i know i know
should we talk about our guest yeah
let's do it
thanks again so we have two amazing
guests on today if you guys haven't
heard of their brand then now you will
you guys could check it out it's called
mad happy and you would just think okay
they're having some
creators of the brand come on to talk
about their business no the underlying
message that this brand has created it
has built upon is mental health and
optimism and positivity and it's just so
much deeper and more than what you would
think it is yeah it's really cool
they're talking about their journey
their friendship of how they met how
they started the brand and they also
give really good advice to people not
only going through
you know some mental health problems and
going through
a failing business and how to recover
and bounce back so we kind of cover
everything and
i think you guys will really enjoy it so
stay tuned for that
[Music]
these designers have changed the way we
typically see fashion through tackling
mental health and promoting positivity
as the driving force the brand was built
on starting in downtown l.a matt happy
has now worked with companies such as
vans pixars artists like ed rushko which
i want to talk about that because i love
art
and more while maintaining their
optimism vision the creators have their
own mental health focus podcast called
the mad happy podcast this is payment
and mason yay
studio audience thank you round of
applause we are so excited i mean i'm
definitely super excited honestly i
don't get nervous for a lot of guests
but i'm nervous for you guys i don't
know if you guys heard my intro i was
like i'm actually very nervous
i was really nervous i don't know what
it is but i think the fact that you guys
started a brand and you're really smart
businessman that intimidates me more
than having you know a comedian or an
actress on or something like that so
thank you guys so much for taking the
time to be here thank you for having us
happy to be here i know we already have
a lot in common we were talking about
off camera that we grew up in the same
area went to sort of the same
neighborhood of schools i just would
love to sort of talk before we get into
the brand matt happy how you guys met
cause it's kind of a cute story
you could tell it payment oh you know
the story okay got it i kind of already
know but the listeners don't know yeah
so i don't fully know i went to beverly
hills high school um and
freshman year became friends with
actually mason's brother matt
so became friends with him he was on the
football team whatever mason went to a
different high school he would start
coming to the games and one day i met
him i was like oh what's up man like
your matt's brother like he's like yeah
mason whatever
and the same like the next week same
game whatever same thing mason's like yo
what was your name like pretending like
he didn't know me
over here nice and uh he pretends like
he doesn't remember that but it's funny
because uh i was just like what's this
kid's deal like he obviously met yeah
there's only one payment no those are
the worst type of people you're like i
know that you know me like and
from that i think over time just became
uh super close friends obviously yeah uh
it's just like always a funny story your
favorite story
and you guys have maintained this
friendship for all these years which is
something you don't really see in l.a
yeah i mean i feel like
i don't know i mean yeah we were super
close in high school and um a lot of the
ways that like mad happy even started
was because of the friendship because
then he became friends with my brother
noah and right and then they started
doing clothing things together so i
don't know yet the thing about payment
that
i think made us so close was like i was
a kid who really struggled academically
started
smoking weed and drinking at an early
age and he was very like clean cut like
one of the smartest kids in school
hadn't really gotten into drugs and
alcohol like at all yet and like we were
so different on paper but i think that
kind of like opposites attract as they
say like led us to really connect and
yeah
it was interesting and then he was super
close with my brother and stuff and he
was always kind of someone that i looked
up to as like someone who was really
hard-working really smart took school
very seriously and was like this is
this is someone i kind of want to stick
around for sure and you can tell that
the friendship in a lot of ways just
complements each other because the
things that you maybe lack he makes up
for and vice versa yeah but sophie and i
were talking about how difficult it is
sort of
being you know related and working on a
business together and trying to grow a
brand together and that sometimes you
can get into some troubled waters and
there could be conflict and that's why
they say never mix business and family
so have you guys ever
had that issue i think i think my take
on that is like one of my partners was
also my brother so i think i could
relate in that way uh very much so which
is like you have your relationship
outside of work and like the
complexities within that and then once
you bring work into that it like only
makes things like harder and like
something that you just have to think
about i think when we started we didn't
really think like oh like how is this
gonna affect our friendship or like my
brother relationship with with noah but
i think now we just try to think about
it talk about it more and it's been like
four and a half years since we started
so i think we're in a lot better of a
place now that and like are aware of it
but i do think it does make it harder
because like your relationship is never
the same as it was before yeah it could
be better or it could be worse so that's
how what was like your commonality
between the friendship was it fashion
did you guys have that because you were
saying you were not as academic but you
were probably i don't know me more
creative in some ways and then yeah so
when we first came up with the idea
payment graduated michigan and then
moved up to new york to work in finance
and then he had been helping us out a
little bit and then ended up getting
sick and had to come home and right
around that time like matt happy really
started to
pick up like just a little bit of steam
of like okay like this is a really cool
name it's a cool concept there's
probably uh something here he was
already helping us from the beginning
and me and noah
didn't graduate from college don't
really have like business savvy minds
are much more creative and he was like
the perfect missing piece to come in and
really be able to like run this business
with us and and really start things off
see that i find so interesting because i
also didn't graduate college and sophia
did and in a lot of ways i kick myself
and i think oh who would take me
seriously
who would want to work with someone that
hasn't graduated college but i really
admire that you know you were able to
continue
you know sort of believing in yourself
because i know a lot of people out there
want to start businesses and want to
start brands but they don't even know
what the right first step is yeah so how
did you guys even
sort of come together come up with mad
happy
decide that like okay we're gonna do
a lifestyle
sweatpant hoodie
brand
yeah i think uh i want to come back to
the college thing later because i think
that's something super interesting that
a lot of kids don't really have the
emotional intelligence or self-awareness
to be able to have those kind of
conversations to even get to that place
so i started another company with
payments brother noah before matt happy
like when we had first i dropped out of
college i was probably 19 or 20. we both
didn't go to fashion school had no idea
what we were doing just kind of hit the
streets of downtown l.a had some like
friends and family in the business and
like learned a little bit from there um
we failed obviously but it was like a
huge lesson because
that after that happened there was a few
months of me
feeling really depressed and just like
not knowing what the hell i was doing
having no direction in my life like i
should have went back to school what am
i doing like i had no job i had no money
and that's when i first thought of the
word like mad happy i was actually
congratulating someone i was like yo i'm
mad happy for you and i just like i was
in my car by myself and it was really
like a light bulb moment and i just
stopped and was like
wow this is like this is very powerful
this feels like not only super
representative of where i am in my life
but something that everyone can really
relate to in their own way and it feels
really big and kind of just like the
essence of life and like made me feel
okay in that moment knowing that like
feeling sad or depressed or having a bad
day is necessary and is like an
inevitable part of life and once we
accept we can really grow and like look
at things from a more whole perspective
so i went to noah like that night
immediately i called him i told him the
name and he loved it and then we just
kind of started like
that's where we came up with the idea of
optimism and the local optimist and like
we didn't even have this whole like
mental health awareness mission at the
time but it was really just like the ups
and downs of life choosing to be an
optimist let's use
fun colors let's have like graphics and
designs that make people feel like they
can express themselves like through
their clothing and maybe like get your
feelings out that way if you're not
ready to talk about them yet right and
that was kind of always our approach i
think anyone who's trying to start a
business or has an idea like the best
ones come from
seeing something that's not in the
market right now um and we didn't feel
like there was that positive optimistic
streetwear brand in the market that was
super inclusive yeah and then having it
just happen very organically um and with
a strong mission i think is like the
biggest key well i was actually gonna
touch on that the fact that you said
that you haven't seen anything like that
in the market because you are tackling
an industry that is like sweatpants
hoodie like it's been done so many times
so what about your brand you knew you
were like okay something is gonna hit
and it's different like what makes mad
happy so
special and stand out from the masses
yeah i think it's also easy to now be
like oh like we knew but like the truth
is also we didn't
know okay what we knew we had was like
this like really good name and really
good idea in that like we grew up in la
and there's all these streetwear brands
and we loved a lot of them but like most
of them felt like you know like [ __ ] you
why are you coming in the store type of
vibe
and we were like why is that like why
can't it be like more inclusive why
can't more people
be part of this like community and so
that's like the vibe we started with
early on and like all of our events were
like a lot bigger and like we would have
these pop-ups and like it would be like
you would want to come to the store even
if you weren't buying anything and so i
think quickly we saw like
the reaction that people were having and
like that kind of made us see that we
were onto something and then we just
built on it from there and then as we
did our first thing like more in like
the mental health space with like a
panel and a pop-up we were like wow like
no one's talking about this like there's
no brand that's ever been like
championing mental health and that was
back in 2017 and obviously a lot's
changing out but no totally and one
thing that i want to touch on because i
remember you just said that when you
didn't go to college you were feeling
like depressed or down and you really
had no direction it's kind of funny
because i went to college and i think
that almost felt like the same way it's
like mental health wasn't really talked
about until i really hit it after i
graduated because i felt like i was
almost more lost leaving college because
i had that structure
and it's the same thing like you didn't
go and you still kind of felt like that
and so i feel like a lot of 20 year olds
with the brand can really really hone in
and relate to it because they're like oh
now there's a word for it or there's a
there's a feeling for it or some there's
a community for it that we can actually
be open and talk about it have you guys
seen a lot of responses from people in
the early 20s that can relate to the
brand or like have opened up and said
that you guys have changed their lives
in some ways absolutely i mean about a
year or a year and a half after we
started mad happy we launched the local
optimist which is like our mental health
resource that lives online and on
instagram where we're constantly like
publishing mental health content whether
they're like tool kits on different
topics or we have this great franchise
called a student series where like kids
in their early 20s we're giving them our
platform to share their own experiences
with a mental health and that's really
where we've built our online community
which like the demographic is largely a
kids in that age and at all of our
pop-ups that we've done we've had these
series of panels on different mental
health topics where like i'm sitting on
them payments moderating we have a
therapist there we have other cool
creators or influencers there and people
that are just willing to talk about the
topics and i always say like some of my
most fulfilling moments since we started
this have been just hearing feedback
from one person about like how that
really made their day or they were
struggling and hearing us talk about
something um really made them look at it
a different way or give them a new
perspective like
that impact and those conversations have
meant the world to me definitely was
there um a moment because you said
before that the mad happy brand wasn't
about mental health when you originally
started it was there a moment in both of
your lives that
you sort of just wanted to change the
direction and focus more about mental
illness yeah i think it was like sort of
a natural part of the brand so like kind
of rewinding when me and mason became
friends like mason was like my first
friend that like i ever talked about
like mental health with like and he
shared a story a bunch like on on the
podcast and and at our panels and so i
think like within that like him thinking
of the name like it was very ingrained
like optimism is a very like mental
health message
in our opinion and so it was really just
like the progression of that so it's
like if you think about a brand like
patagonia and like what they've been
able to do for like sustainability like
all of what they've been able to do over
the many many years like it didn't all
start like at the beginning right and so
they kept layering things on and so for
us like maybe it started with the
clothing and then it was like the panels
and then it was the local optimist and
now it's the podcast and now we have a
bunch of other things we just partnered
with penn on a research program and so
like we just feel like if we layer in
things year after year then when you
look back 10 20 years like we'll have
made a big impact and so i think the
mental health thing was always there for
us it was just like figuring out like
what our role was in the space you know
like we're not providing therapy we're
not providing care we're just like the
brand that like wants to make it okay to
talk about and then like help lead you
on your way to where you're going you
guys are extremely relatable by the way
yeah like it's extremely relatable and i
feel like that's why you can put a face
to the brand it makes it a lot more
comforting and it's not just something
that you can't really touch you can
actually relate to you and you can also
connect with you guys not just through
the clothing but like the owners
themselves
for people that are starting their
business young and they don't really
know what they're doing what would you
say to them as like when you were
starting your early stages what was
something that was a guiding factor or
like what would you say
kept you motivated yeah i mean i think
and i'm curious what mason thinks but i
think for
for me um this is like the best time to
start your own thing right in like the
history of the world right like you can
start a shopify store like anyone can
right and it's like 20 a month to start
so i think the younger you are you think
there's like all this like risk to
everything you're doing like like
dropping out of college or like oh my
god my life is over uh but if you really
think about it like that's like the
least risky time of your life because
you don't have a family you don't have
obligations yeah all these other things
that maybe when you're older become
harder and so i think like what we talk
about is like if if you are called to
like start something like even how we
started mad happy was just like a small
way to try to like see if it was working
versus like oh my god like this is my
only thing and like if mad happy failed
then we were on to like the next thing
right and so i think having the mindset
of just like trying and like the earlier
you try the better off you'll be and
really asking people for help that you
know or just reaching out to them like
on on dms and stuff i think helped us so
much so
that would be my advice no you guys have
a really good team with you because i
know that for me a lot of the times
whenever i was trying to start something
i had so much doubt in my head and i
think that it was really nice to have
sistine by my side and you guys probably
motivated each other whenever someone
had doubt it's not really give up and
just keep going i mean did you guys ever
have a feeling where you were like this
isn't going to work and like how did you
get over that
or were you guys conscious i didn't
really have the feeling like this wasn't
gonna work i was like going through a
lot of things like personally where i
was like i don't know if i can do this
or like having doubts in myself or just
like really struggling with like
depression or my addictions and like not
knowing if i could continue and like
actually
three years ago in the summer of 2018
like i hit my rock bottom and had to go
away for treatment and i had no idea
like if i would stay with the brand or
like what i was going to be able to do
and like i was so grateful for my
partners during that time to like
listen to me and really hear me and be
able to like take a bigger load on their
plate like while i stepped away so that
was for me personally but i think in
terms of the brand like
people were so hungry for something like
this that
we grew a lot faster than i could have
ever imagined and like there was never
really that moment of like
oh [ __ ] i think there was just that
moment of like this is crazy like
what's next i want to touch on that
because i think a lot of people and
certainly myself understands and and can
relate to the way that you were feeling
in 2018 yeah what were the certain steps
that you took maybe it was the responses
from mad happy following was it seeking
therapy what sort of steps did you take
to help you get out of that place yeah
so like i i had been in therapy for i've
been in therapy since i was seven years
old so like therapy was nothing new for
me i was always working with someone
like payment said even back in middle
school and high school like i was that
kid that was super emotional that was
talking about their feelings was
sensitive was like super early on mental
health and even then i still wasn't
really doing the work or getting the
help i need right like we could all
exactly like me by the way
we could all go into a therapy session
and like talk our way out of the room or
like we get smart like we know what they
want to hear and what to say and just
get through that hour and like
unfortunately it wasn't until like i hit
my rock bottom and i was having like
suicidal ideation and like i didn't want
to be here anymore and i'm just making
everyone's life harder that then i was
like holy [ __ ] i'm absolutely terrified
i don't recognize who i am right now and
then what payment said about asking for
help that is the most important thing
that anyone can do is to reach out to
someone in their support system online
in person a parent a family member
whatever to tell them that you're
struggling and then that's what really
like set me on my path and i think i i
scared myself so much with how
how low i went that i was like i never
want to feel like that again and i'm
willing to like get sober i'm willing to
go to 12-step meetings i'm willing to
like go to treatment i'm willing to cut
these friends out of my life i'm willing
to change these lifestyle habits like
i'm willing to build my world however i
need to do it so i never get back to
that place and now something that i'm so
passionate about and very vocal about is
like how can we meet people and kids
before they get to that place to show
them that it's important so we can save
lives and get people started on their
path and get them taking mental health
more seriously before it gets too dark
right and i so i can relate that to that
immensely because i struggle with
anxiety disorder my whole life and if
you know me my sister knows my family
knows i've always been the one that's
vocal about therapy my anxiety mental
health and even when my family didn't
really talk about it i was the one that
was pioneering it so i'd go to therapy
sessions for
literally my entire life but i felt like
i was saying everything but not saying
the right thing in the sense that i
wasn't really i was thinking okay i'm
gonna put a band-aid on it i'd go to
these set sessions i'd be like okay you
know i'm doing the work but i'm not
really doing the work and it hit a point
i think like last year that i was like i
really do need to like
take charge of this because this is just
like i'm setting myself back months and
months when i could have been doing the
work the whole time and i think that is
so it's key to be so much more
communicative about
what is going on your life and like
getting the help you need and just being
totally honest that you do need help and
it's okay to ask for help i mean this
life is it's hard it's not life isn't
supposed to be easy you're gonna have
your ups and downs there's gonna be [ __ ]
you're gonna have to go through and it's
like we're like a car you need to oil
yourself up sometimes you have to go to
therapy to like fix or find tuna or talk
to someone or write it out and i'm
really happy that you did that and you
guys are both like vocal about it
because i think it's such a stigma when
it doesn't really need to be and it
feels weird even talking about like i
don't think it's weird talking about it
maybe i understand that some people have
uncomfortableness about opening up
depending if it's their family or
religion whatever the circumstances are
but it's so good even with your podcast
like you guys are really open about it i
mean what made you guys want to start a
podcast
after having the mad happy brand was
that kind of always the idea because you
guys are tackling
99 things i mean you're you're having a
panel you're doing the pop-ups you're
doing yeah
like you have so many different things
going it's like let's just throw a pot
let's do one more let's just do it what
made the podcast um i think similar to
like how we started the brand and like
we saw that like oh like we're like the
only brand that's like so focused on
like making mental health conversations
yeah you really are yeah
normal and now there's a lot of people
doing it but um which is amazing i think
for us like we were always interested in
the in the podcast side of things
because we felt like it was like you
said like that personal layer that
connects people to the brand and also
allows us to
really bring a lot of people into the
conversation right so if you have these
different high caliber guests on and
they're talking about their mental
health then like all the kids listening
are like oh
like dixie demilio talked about it on
the manhattan podcast so it's fine for
me to also talk about right and she's
talking about and and mason brought this
up when we had her which is like
everyone has like the six or seven like
same like core feelings like so like
everyone's experience is so similar yeah
and and so if you can relate to someone
who you think that like it has the best
life ever
done like same thing with mason right
like our business was going great but
like he was like in the worst place that
he had ever been in in his life and so i
think like with that same point like we
just tried to like start something that
we felt like would impact a lot of
people and and by listening to like
these people or just listening to our
stories hopefully you could better
relate and then like you take whatever
the next step is for you whether that's
just like continuing to listen or
reaching out to someone or
getting help well honestly i feel like
you guys having a podcast helps my
anxiety because simply your voices are
so soothing i swear to god no we
actually did say that we didn't say that
we were like super annoying on camera
and on audio like they're really like
professional stuff but um
you guys have had some killer guests on
your show and i was telling sophia like
you've had no back you've had logic
you've had
dixie ashley tisdale i mean
is there a guest that
kind of surprised you when you're
interviewing them and you didn't think
that that would come out and they would
be so vulnerable
uh for me my favorite guest has been
rami uh he's like a writer and director
that has a show on hulu and i was a huge
fan of the show and it had so many
different mental health themes and
topics and like one of my favorite parts
is like it's really about um his
character within his muslim american
family living in new jersey and like we
spend time with everyone in the family
and everyone has their own [ __ ] going on
like the dad is actually fired but
pretends to go to work uncle's gay and
doesn't tell anyone the sister like
hates the family or whatever and like no
one tells anyone ever like anything and
they're just like sitting at the table
and to me it's just like the perfect
representation of like mental health and
like what you were saying about like
struggling with anxiety and your family
and like it's so hard for us to tell the
people that are supposed to like care
for us and love us the most because
they're like might be the hardest to be
vulnerable with or we're scared that
they're going to judge us or like our
parents have done so much for us that i
don't want to like let them know that
i'm struggling and to me that's just
like so silly because like those are
supposed to be the people in our corner
more than anyone so to be able to talk
to him about uh religion and just like
other things that we don't usually cover
on the show was a really cool episode
yeah for sure i think that point is like
so good in that like
we find that the people we bring on the
show sometimes like it feels like
they're sharing way more than they share
with anyone else and that's sort of like
a weird concept right because it's like
how are you not sharing this with like
the people closest to you i even find
like myself like i'm sharing so much
more than like i even share sometimes
with my girlfriend or with my brother or
with my parents so i'm like the show is
set up in a way where hopefully people
can like be comfortable and we could
actually like talk about like real
things and like all of our experiences
at the end of the day are so similar
that like it's just like i found it to
be like a super like relatable show are
you gonna pick a favorite or no yeah
pick a favorite yeah also it's the brown
eyes apparently everyone opens up to
people that brown oh yeah yeah oh
perfect yeah
so
um i really liked this was an early
episode but emma chamberlain she was
dope um and
we had been like fans of like her work
and stuff but like we had never spoken
to her and and for someone like so young
to like really like have thought about
all these things and she has an amazing
podcast that very much has a mental
health message uh i think she was a
really good one and it was super early
but like the conversation was amazing
you know i think having people like emma
on like rami on
you say that oh i wasn't expecting
me to open up so much of them to open up
so much but i also don't think that
they're ever questioned about like are
you okay how are you feeling it's more
so what they're promoting something or
talking about something superficial so i
think it's really cool because it's true
the more you have people with large
followings talking about it everyone
else will seem more comfortable to talk
about it i know that i have never been
one to vocalize the way that i feel
about my anxiety or or
all of that jazz because i didn't want
to disappoint my parents and i didn't
want to disappoint sofia and i wanted to
stay strong for her because i knew that
she was going through anxiety so so
that's a great i think of like you
didn't because in your mind opening up
would have made you seem weak and like
that's the biggest thing like we're
trying to turn like no one's championing
this ab better than brene brown but like
vulnerability is the ultimate act of
courage right so like if you really
wanted to be strong for sophia or
whatever like by opening up and like
going down in that hole that she was in
and sitting down like a next door and
putting her arm around her like that's
that's the idea of strength that like
we're trying to teach that like is the
thing that isn't clicking for most
people because of like the way that
society is right now oh my god and i
know you would love it if i did that to
you oh yeah i know because this chicken
presses everything and all of a sudden
she knocks over a glass of water and
she's wailing about the water i'm like
this is not a water spilled milk i don't
know it's not really the worst it's okay
that's true keeps our really [ __ ] fun
yeah we still excited
is there a dream guest that you guys
would love to have on besides us
obviously
that was a joke you guys can laugh
they're like shut up you go first we've
actually been asked this on the show i
mean i think there's
there's a lot of people i would say like
the rock i would love to have the rock
he's our neighbor he yeah we'll set it
up yeah we'll knock on his door throw a
pebble at his window yeah exactly
i think it's cool because he's like you
know everyone sees him as like this like
you know super like strong like doing a
million things so successful but like
obviously like everyone has like their
own story and their things that they're
dealing with um but one other funny
thing on the guest thing which is like
sometimes we're like oh like we wonder
like how this guest is going to be or
like we're not as like
we're like is this one going to be good
and like the truth is that like all of
them are good because like everyone's
just like a human and like there's like
an amazing story behind every person and
so i think we often get surprised by the
people that we know the least going into
it yeah um and i think that that's a
cool thing about the show that it's like
not only focused on like the top tier
celebrities because it's nice when you
meet someone that you don't really know
and then they have so many layers to
them and i think it's the worst when
people are always like oh like they seem
perfect like i want something bad to be
like happening to them what's wrong yeah
like what's wrong with them they need to
have a problem like everyone has a
problem you just start changing the
language of it and making it okay it's
now a safer space and i think you can
learn a lot from someone when you don't
really know them at all because then you
don't have any expectations and then you
don't assume like oh they might be just
like having this slight anxiety and
that's how it's going to be like it's
fun when you can kind of gamble and just
see who is gonna pop up i know i hope we
have the rock on that'd be kind of cool
maybe we should just we're stealing your
guests um i remember for
i think it was mental health awareness
month you guys have put out a bunch of
billboards and one of them read or i
think all of them but in different
languages was it treat yourself like
someone you love exactly i do not know
why
and i'm not one to read billboards but i
looked at it and it just hit me so hard
i was like what
did you guys come up with this
how does it resonate with you because it
really hit me like a [ __ ]
semi-truck oh yeah the best way in the
best it was something that my mom uh
came up with and like told me a lot um
in like my late teenage years and early
20s like as i was struggling and i think
to us
what it means or to me what it means is
like we're our own toughest critic and
like for me it's like so much easier to
like be there for payment and give him
the best advice and relationship advice
and personal advice and all these things
and like turn around and not take any of
it like myself and we're often like so
hard on ourselves like our anxiety in
our head we're like negative self-talk
all day all day and like so worried
about all these things and it's just
kind of like a gentle reminder to be
more kind to yourself and like treat
yourself as you would someone you love a
friend a family member uh because we're
often just like way too hard on
ourselves and not grateful and not just
like really loving ourselves even though
we give all this love to all these other
people um kind of the most important
person to give it to what do you hardest
on yourselves about because i know for
me it's like if i'm not perfect at
something like i'm a perfectionist i
love when i can't if i get it wrong it
really hits me hard and i need to have
cesine tell me especially if you fail at
something yeah if i feel like i take it
really personally on myself i'm like
everyone else can like mess up if i mess
up
i think it is just like i ruined it for
everybody and i just like it so that's
like the perfect example of like if she
messed up you would still give her a hug
but if you messed up you'd be pissing
yourself like you're forgiving yourself
you guys have that type of thing like is
there something that you get really hard
on yourself about
for me i mean i think i've always been
like very competitive about everything
so just trying to like compete with
myself and like not really like give
myself like breaks or like time off or
things like that that i think
i'm super hard on myself about but i
think i have gotten a lot better at this
year um
i actually started going to therapy in
january so i've been going like every
week
for 11 months and i feel like it's like
the first time that i've really been
able to like think about myself more
because like often i'm very like outward
facing like what do we need to do like
for the company or right all these like
people in my life that i try to help but
like helping myself is like the most
important thing for sure um so
you have to know yourself you live with
yourself i mean and then i think on the
billboard thing i think for us like that
was our first time doing billboards we
we did it in may and it was like
every billboard you see is always just
like selling something but we weren't
selling anything with them and it was
just like a messaging campaign of just
like making people's like days a little
bit better and we actually have the
treat yourself like someone you love in
all of our like like hang tags in our
products so i think it's just like
another place that like that originated
and we were like this is like a great
message like let's put it out i love it
because one of my favorite things is um
you accept the love you think you
deserve i'm always like why do i deserve
bad love like come on
no really but i i thought it was so
genius um
and it really helped me a lot when i
read it
i have kind of an interesting question
um
if if you guys were your younger selves
right now
and you saw what you're doing right now
with the awareness that you're putting
out and the message that you're
spreading what would you tell yourself
i've always just like been so insecure
and like feel stupid all the time
because i was never good at school and i
only have one semester of college under
my belt that i would probably just me
too yeah we're still freshmen it's great
but i probably just tell that kid like
it doesn't matter that you're struggling
so hard in the classroom like life is
way bigger than this and like you are
enough and like you don't have to feel
sad all the time and like you're smart
and just because it's not in that way
doesn't mean that it can't be in another
way and just
like love yourself more and like you're
enough dude i love that yeah that's good
i wish i could tell myself that too but
yeah i could go yeah um i think i think
for me like the way that i always like
feel progress in my own life is like
looking back a year and i'm like oh my
god like i was like an idiot back then
or like there's so much happen in like
the company's life and and so for me
like i think looking back i always like
kind of had this like mentality of like
just like if i keep going and if i keep
doing like the right things which is
like working hard like being a good
person all those things that it'll all
work out so like i think i would just
like give myself the message of just
like keep going and you know
eventually something great will happen
and so i think that's how i've tried
always in my life and the advice i give
other people that are younger too right
a final question where are you guys
taking the mad happy brand next yeah
what's next what's next like what are
you guys looking forward to trying to
make this into like a like a live tour
type of thing collaboration oh yeah tour
um you guys should sell at stadiums
so with you guys yeah yeah we give you
the next tony robbins
yeah we are the openers
let's do some
i think for us like we still feel like
it's so early like only four and a half
years in but
if you look at brands like nike and
patagonia that have been around for like
50 plus years like
it's really just like so so early and so
for us the way we think about it is like
a brand now is like much more than just
like one thing right so of course we
have our apparel and like we want to
make products that make people feel good
and we're going to continue to do that
uh we're going to scale out like our
retail so like we want to have locations
in like all the major cities in the
world and and really bring that
experience all across like the world and
then the second piece is like on the
accessory side we release this product
like a mental health journal in may and
that's a product that's more geared to
the space that we want to be everywhere
right so we just launched it with 25
companies buying it for all their
employees like live nation we're
launching it um we're giving it back to
a lot of schools and so that product we
want to be everywhere products like that
yeah and then the third piece is a
content piece which mason could talk on
more but that includes obviously our
things like the local optimist the
podcast and more to come there yeah i
think we just want to like
since day one our mission has been to
create conversation around mental health
and i think like to amplify our
megaphone and be able to tell stories
that inspire people to talk about their
mental health both scripted and
non-scripted and there's so much
opportunity in that space that i think
we're super excited to see how we can
grow there and the podcast has been huge
for us and then how we can continue to
grow the local optimists with more video
content like some longer form stuff we
also have like a thing called the local
optimus hotline which is like a
non-crisis support text line that i
definitely want to continue to grow out
and just like be able to take this thing
on the road and like really look at all
those kids in the highs and really talk
to them about our stories and hear what
they're thinking and how we can cater
more to them and just continue to
inspire people and get them to start to
take their mental health more seriously
you guys are unstoppable i can't wait to
see what you all do next thank you guys
so much for coming on the show and being
so vulnerable and open and creating a
brand that's really helping a lot of
people look i'm wearing mad happy right
now and i already feel better so uh tell
everyone where they can find your
instagrams mad happy your podcast
everything yeah big shout out to our
podcast for sure um the mad happy
podcast uh you can find it apple spotify
really anywhere so would love for people
to check that out and then we're just at
mad happy on on instagram at local
optimist local optimist and uh you'll be
able to find our personals if you really
want to there all right start digging
y'all yeah thank you thank you for
having us really oh i appreciate you we
got to get you guys on too oh yeah well
we'll definitely do it if you guys did
thank you guys so much for tuning in
this week we will see you next tuesday
bye guys bye
[Music]